des poissons inanimés flottants à la
surface du ruisseau de Saint-Roch sur
environ 3 km c'était en septembre 2020
la station d'épuration Veolia toute
proche en travaux à l'époque semblait
tant d'être la cause et erreur
imprudence ou manque d'anticipation et
d'évaluation des risques le process se
déroulait aujourd'hui Franck Laval
notre métier c'est de dépolluer pas
l'inverse l'entreprise n'est pas fière
de ce qui s'est passé confronté aux
preuves le représentant de Veolia
reconnaît à la barre la pollution sur le
ruisseau de Saint-Roch mais le jure elle
est le résultat d'erreur individuelles
pas d'une politique globale de Veolia
car l'affaire est sensible à l'heure de
l'urgence écologique d'ailleurs avant
même les débats les avocats de Veolia
ainsi que le directeur territorial
annonçait un accord avec les parties
civils pour restaurer le cours d'eau un
de nos agents à commu une erreur
l'entreprise est là aussi pour l'assumer
on est vraiment navré que ça ait cet
impact sur le milieu et c'est pour ça
qu'on se doit et on veut le réparer
septembre 2020 l'entreprise entame en
urgence des travaux sur la station
d'épuration de Saint-Roch une dérivation
est alors installée vers le ruisseau où
sont rejetés les eaux pré-trétées
tolérable pour des fleuves comme la
Loire cette libération des fluant encore
polluée est en revanche beaucoup moins
pour des ruisseaux cette pollution a
conduit à la mort de plusieurs centaines
de poissons sur 3 km de cours d'eau
pourquoi dès lors avoir poursuivi ces
rejets pourquoi avoir attendu la
découverte de la pollution par la
fédération de pêche pour mettre en place
une solution alternative ou encore
pourquoi n'avoir prévenu la direction
départementale des territoires que le
jour du début du travaux au lieu du mois
légal je ne sais pas
erreur du responsable du site plaide
encore le représentant de Veolia le
ministère public car Rocky 60 000 euros
d'amende ainsi que la publication du
jugement dans la presse se délibérer est
attendu le 22 novembre